so the x-men first class being a lot
better than a whole bunch of people
thought it was gonna be I've started to
become a little more interested in
whatever they're gonna do with Wolverine
- Darren Aronofsky was gonna direct it
night when I heard that I was like are
you serious
because he's like a really good
independent director but he left the
film and it's been in a lingo for a
while but today they finally announced
that they have a director for watering -
James Mangold that makes me really happy
because I don't know if you guys know
who he is but he's directed a lot of
really good movies Kate and Leopold
which was cut above the average romantic
comedy with really likable performances
also with Hugh Jackman that's gonna be
in the new Wolverine movie identity I
think is a really underrated thriller
starring John Cusack and Ray Liotta very
psychological and different than the
average you know creep fest he directed
walk the line the Johnny Cash movie with
Joaquin Phoenix and Reese Witherspoon
which was a really good and very strong
dramatic piece of great music and just
great acting overall the remake of 3:10
to Yuma which is an excellent Western
Styne Christian Bale and Russell Crowe
that movie was really fun and intense
and he made night and day with Tom
Cruise and Cameron Diaz which although
some people didn't really buy into I had
a lot of fun with he also made the
film's heavy
Copland and Girl Interrupted which I
have not seen but every movie I've seen
from this director I've liked he's a
very strong director and he's really
talented in regards to action scenes but
he does not allow the emotional aspects
of film to die down either the director
of the first Wolverine movie had
literally no experience in regards to
action scenes or Hollywood mainstream
entertainment but James Mangold has
experience in like every genre he's made
of romance film a horror movie a Western
straight action films and walk the line
which is a musical drama and I am now
very optimistic about the fact that
they're making another Wolverine movie I
really like Hugh Jackman as that
character and I was hoping we wouldn't
see the end of his role because he's
just really talented as Wolverine he is
he is Wolverine he's perfect that's
oliver him he's the only thing in the
first Wolverine movie that I thought was
good I mean the rest was just terrible
but he was good so what do you guys
think about James Mangold directing will
rain - I personally think it's a really
good idea in this series is heading in a
good direction let me know you guys
think below and on a side note my new
blog is up on the schmoes no comm
website it's about super 8 and why movie
trailers are ruining movies